it's great to be joined today by Jeremy
Lent founder of the nonprofit Li ology
Institute and author of the new book the
patterning instinct the cultural history
of humanity search for meaning Jeremy
the the timing of our interview couldn't
be better because we recently
interviewed Peter Joseph of the
zeitgeist movement whose new book deals
quite a bit with this idea that the
status quo of humanity on earth is not
some sort of obvious inevitability that
could not have gone some other way but
really the result of the structures and
systems that humans have put in place
throughout civilization and and that's
something your book deals quite a lot
with isn't it yes that is so true and
yeah as you say there's such a parallel
there basically the underlying theme of
my book is that and different cultures
really create their own set of values
and those values they have the one have
shaped history and you know the book
goes all the way back from hunt together
at times to the present day and looks at
how different cultural values of shake
history but I think that may be the most
important thing to take from that is
that the values that we holds today in
our culture and that is that we choose
to live by going to shape our future
and let's start maybe with you mentioned
hunter-gatherers and I've read quite a
bit about the way in which we we saw the
Agricultural Revolution not only bring
major advances for Homo sapiens but also
create new issues right inequality and
great art dates back to the starting to
to talk about our land this is my plot
of land hunger disease famine etc but
sometimes some of those accounts sort of
romanticize the hunter-gatherer era of
humanity talk a little bit about that
because you discuss in the book that
that when humans were at the phase of
being hunter-gatherers it was not the
panacea that we sometimes see it as yeah
I think that's so true and sometimes
these debates like this other than
notable Savage kind of thing versus you
know we need an institutional and so
organization because the life of humans
by themselves is nasty brutish and short
sometimes these debates get kind of
polarized according to modern political
viewpoints and lose a lot of I think
what's really interesting is the nuance
but and below that so in terms of
hunter-gatherers there is a lot we can
learn actually from the way they
organized their communities together but
there's also a lot we can learn from and
the imbalances that they created so
something that most people don't know is
that it was actually while humans were
hunter-gatherers tens even hundreds of
thousands of years ago that we actually
created and some of the greatest mass
extinctions in all of the Earth's
history so you know when and when humans
first left Africa and went to Asia and
then to Australia and then went across
Siberia to the Americas they just
thought well nature is so bountiful all
these big mammals out there and of
course those melons had no instinctive
fear of humans the humans had this power
of having be able to develop tools so
over a number of generations they led to
these mass extinctions about
three-quarters of what's called the
megafauna of North and South America
went extinct and over ninety percent of
Australia's megafauna went extinct and I
think the lesson we can learn from that
is the how humans can create these
imbalances and with the natural world
oftentimes without even being aware of
it when you talk about imbalances I mean
right now it's hard to avoid having a
conversation about climate change and in
the book of course you're not arguing we
shouldn't worry about climate change but
you do talk about how if we fix climate
change whatever form that solution
ultimately takes that humanity will
create some new existential threat can
you talk about why you feel so strongly
about that yes and I do think that is so
important for us to understand because I
think we need
to recognize the climate change is
really more of a symptom of what's wrong
with our our place in the in the world
in our relationship with the natural
world and relationship with ourselves
and rather than of course of something
so it's a little bit like the canary in
the mind that is the early sign that
there are some really deep imbalances
and I think if you just look at a deeper
place you see that our whole and global
system encourages us to consume at this
growing rate and and everything about
our values is based on this notion the
consumption and growth and consumption
is necessary for human flourishing and I
think the opposite in fact is true and
that right now we're on a an increase
accelerating course towards a precipice
that is not just in relation to climate
change but in relation to the ways in
which we we are causing now our own
sixth mass extinction of species and
we're utilizing resources at a
completely unsustainable rate including
things like freshwater and ocean fish
and leading to significant deforestation
desertification around the world all
these kind of issues are connected with
each other and if we try to just solve
one issue alone like climate change what
we're really doing is just kind of
kicking the can down the road until a
next bigger issue hits us so what needs
to change more systemically yeah I think
that what we need to do is shift some of
the underlying values that lead us as a
global civilization to this behavior of
ever-increasing consumption like into
them and if you think of our wealth
system like some kind of software and
it's as though we keep getting bigger
and bigger software glitches and we keep
trying to fix those glitches but what we
really need to do is look at the
operating system underneath and that
operating system in our current world
view our current way of finding meaning
has to do with things like and
consumerism
and this desire for growth in
possessions and for growth and status in
terms of what we consume as being what
leads to a sense of meaning in life
rather than other ways of finding
meaning that are more sustainable well
to take your software analogy it seemed
if we tweak it set slightly it seems
that the world approach to dealing with
issues calamities is sort of that of
creating a software patch which prevents
the entire program from ceasing to
function but if you keep patching the
same piece of outdated software
eventually it will no longer work with
the hardware and it maybe there's
something there to that analogy in terms
of the human approach to solving
problems but at the same time when
you're talking about billions of humans
dealing with complex interrelated
problems isn't it just from a practical
level very difficult to get worldwide
consensus on any problem yes I think
it's very difficult to get worldwide
consensus on any problem and yet what
we've seen is there are there are
moments in history when something like
that has happened so if you just think
back a couple of hundred years ago and
slavery was considered to be as
essential to and the sort of an optimal
working of the modern world at that time
as global capitalism is considered now
but at what as a certain level of
cultural evolution occurred something
shifted in the sense of what is right
what we're somewhere meaning arises and
when morality arises and so now even
though of course and there are incidents
still of slavery happening in the world
virtually everyone in the world agrees
that that's a bad thing and that should
be illegal so there are these shifts
that happen and in spite of what seems
to be like overwhelming odds and to me
that is a source of hope even as we look
at some of the really quite and yeah
quite terrifying directions we're going
in right now well there are numerous
futurists and scientists that believe
we're at a sort of inflection point
right now so
a Kurtz file for example when it comes
to technological development believes
that we are in the middle of an
inflection point although it can be
difficult to feel that when you're in
the middle of it
Aubrey de Grey who does research into
longevity believes that that the first
person who will live a thousand years
has already been born and that we are at
a sort of accelerating point of
longevity do you believe that number one
and number two what are the factors
about life today that will impact where
humanity goes yes and first I do agree
that we are at a major inflection point
issue here the book looks all through
the sweep of history and we sing two
major transformations in these human
experience really from when we were
first time together was the first of
those was with the rise of Agriculture
about ten to twelve thousand years ago
and the second of those was with the
scientific and industrial revolution
that occurred just a few hundred years
ago and we're still experiencing the
impact of that now and I think there's a
lot of reasons to believe that this
century we are going to be experiencing
the third great transformation of
humanity and it's like my last chapter
and look it actually called trajectories
to our future and it looks at some of
these trajectories it looks at one and
which is this kind of Raymond Kurzweil
kind of idea of what's known as a
singularity where technology and
converging technologies all need for
such a drastic change that the whole
meaning of being human is changed
forever
it also looks at the possibility of
collapse of our civilization and it
looks at the third possibility of a
possible and sustainable flourishing for
Humanity and then and so the one of the
things I do think we need to be very
aware of is when we're looking at some
of these high-tech and optimistic views
of the cells engineer person who's
already been born or and what we can do
with neural interfaces to the internet
or whatever for I get so afraid that
these people oftentimes are just
focusing on the a leaps
it within the whole human race at
seven-and-a-half billion of us as the
people who get the benefits of that so
there's a scenario that I call techno
splits where basically and the the
people who are currently the and the
elite in the world may be the wealthiest
half billion or so get to enjoy genetic
enhancement neural interfaces and maybe
do get to live for hundreds of years or
whatever but meanwhile billions of other
human beings are suffering essentially a
collapse from climate change and all
these other environmental disasters that
are hitting us I think that's a very
important issue for us to be aware of
whenever we hear are some of these kind
of hopeful optimistic scenarios because
if you're like me your sense of being a
human being is not just being this
individual and rejecting our sense of
connection with others but there's a
really powerful sense of us being a
human family and we need to be really
focused on the idea that technological
advance is there for all of humanity not
just for an elite year well the book is
fascinating it's called the patterning
instinct the cultural history of
humanity search for meaning we've been
speaking with the book's author Jeremy
Lenz
Jeremy thank you so much for talking to
me about this today yeah thank you very
much David